هنا من فوق الركام في
منطقه المحافظه الوسطى ما بين مخيم البريج
والنصيرات المنطقه الغربيه لمخيم البريج
وهي تقع يعني ايضا المنطقه الشرقيه لمخيم
النصيرات هذا الخراب هو يعني من جرافات
الاحتلال جرفت شارع صلاح
الدين يعني هنا خراب ودمار لكل
شيء دمر عدد من كبير من الشقق من الشقق
السكنيه في هذه العماره
ويعني ان دلاعه حرائق كبيره وهي غير صالحه
للسكن بعد هذا
ال استمعتم الى اطلاق النار نتابع
هنا دخان كثيف بالقرب من مدخل
البريج في هذه المناطق تتواجد اليات
الاحتلال ويتواجد جنود الاحتلال اطلاق
قذائف دخانيه في تلك المنطقه ويعني اشتعال
النيران وحرائق تندلع نتيجه قصف الاحتلال
لمنازل المواطنين وكذلك ورش العمل ورش
المواطنين هنا كانت تتواجد الاليات
والجرافات
للاحتلال تدمير كامل
لهذه يعني هذه المنطقه تدمير
كامل لكل
شيء
بداخلها طواقم الدفاع المدني ثرت هنا على
يعني قذائف من مخلفات الاحتلال هنا كمان
واحده هذه القذائف يعني تتحدث الطواقم
الان لعدد من المواطنين قد وصلوا هذه
المنطقه وحذروه من يعني المساس بهذه
المخلفات حتى لا تنفجر هذه القذائف ب يعني
الشبان دمار
كبير في هذا المكان نستمع لاطلاق
نار يعني يبدو هناك قناصه للاحتلال في
احدى يعني المباني في مخيم البريج